Look at this footage from Ecuador.
It is a bunch of masked men
who invaded a TV station
while it was still live on the air.
Ecuador is a place
that has historically been peaceful
and beautiful.
Recently, it's
been descending into chaos.
A few weeks ago,
this drug lord
who was serving 34 years
in prison, escaped.
Then, all hell broke loose.
Prisons were taken over by the inmates.
Guards were held hostage.
Police officers abducted.
And then, of course,
this TV station incident.
Stuff like this is happening
all over the country.
And the reason it's happening
now is because the cocaine trade
is changing.
A lot more drugs are going to Europe.
Drug cartels are using
this port in Ecuador
as a major trade hub.
The number of violent deaths
has doubled since last year.
A presidential candidate
that was running on
anti-corruption was assassinated
as well as the prosecutor
who was investigating
this TV station incident.
So now, like Mexico and Colombia, Ecuador
is descending into a drug war
between these gangs and the government.
And it is tearing the country apart
I'm going to keep following this.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.